[Musique]
et cet invité est en ligne avec nous
depuis la région de pavie en italie
bonjour midi d'abord bonjour ça va ça va
et vous merci beaucoup de prendre le
temps de répondre à nos questions de
l'eau vous êtes vous avez 26 ans mehdi
des bras et vous êtes en train de
réaliser un projet absolument dingue
relier paris à alger à pied en autonomie
ou presque vous êtes partis il y à un
peu plus d'un mois c'était le 5 mai
dernier vous avez fait en gros un gros
quart de votre voyage mille kilomètres
on vous voit tasse de café à la main
comment ça va d'abord et dites nous ce
que vous êtes allé faire dans cette
galère ça va super et
pour pour soutenir une association
d'hommes à mon père à travers à travers
l'association et faire une surprise
aussi à mon grand
voile à paris vous étiez serveurs et
puis effectivement il ya eu le décès de
votre papa qui vous a donné envie de
faire ce projet alors vous aviez déjà
beaucoup marcher dans votre dans votre
dans votre vie vous marchez dit vous en
mémoire de celui qui vous a vu faire vos
premiers pas exactement ça vous marchez
donc pour une association qui s'appelle
life ong les gens qui vous suivent et
ils sont nombreux on va en reparler
peuvent participer aux projets que vous
soutenez c'est la construction d'un
château d'eau au togo racontez nous
c'est ça ben j'ai reçu les premières
images hier soir on voit c'est dans un
petit village on voit l'eau jaillir du
sol et entendu les gens super content
donc c'était hier soir c'était assez
émouvant
du coup l'objectif c'était du métro on
est déjà à 25 me donc je pense qu'il y
aura sûrement plusieurs châteaux d'eau
et d'autres actions ont encore mené avec
l'association bon est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter comment ça se passe votre
voyage là je le dis vous avez déjà fait
à peu près 1000 km il vous en reste 3000
à quoi ressemble journée alors mes
journées voilà j'ai
j'ai pris ma tante mes affaires et sont
quasiment prêtes et je marche en moyenne
30 km par jour je prends mon temps pour
visiter je prends mon temps avec les
gens aussi pour faire des rencontres et
je me mets pas de pression en terme de
timing je fais vraiment ma petite
promenade comme si souvent jusqu'à alger
je crois que vous craignez plusieurs
choses l'épreuve physique bien sûr mais
surtout la solitude en fait c'est assez
fou c'est que vous êtes loin d'être seul
vous êtes suivi par des dizaines de
milliers de personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis vous croisez beaucoup de
gens sur la route qui vous connaissent
qui vous reconnaissent c'est incroyable
jusqu'en italie il ya des gens parfois
qui passe balazs en train de boire un
thé par exemple ils étaient suisses ont
passé me ramener du thé en italie pour
pour me dire bonjour parce que dans une
de mes story sur sur instagram j'avais
dit que j'avais j'avais besoin d'aidé
ils sont passés en fait j'ai dû soutient
vraiment de partout c'est incroyable
vous dites que vous êtes partis à la
recherche de la meilleure version de
vous même c'est la meilleure version de
l'humanité que vous croisez sur la route
là depuis le départ ouais je rencontre
que des gens magnifiques vraiment qu'ils
me suivent ou qui ne suivent pas je
reçois tout le temps de l'aide
par exemple se croit où j'ai trouvé où
dormir je j'ai demandé aux habitants si
ça dérangeait pas parce que là je suis
je suis pas très loin d'un immeuble en
vrai j'ai trouvé que ce coin là mais
sont vraiment sur des gens gentils que
ce soit en france en suisse en italie et
j'espère encore en tunisie en algérie
voilà parce que après l'italie donc vous
allez rejoindre alors y aura un petit
coup de bateaux quand même j'imagine la
tunisie puis l'algérie donc faire une
surprise à votre grand père on va y
revenir dans un instant est-ce que vous
vous attendiez à être autant suivi
autant soutenir à recevoir autant de
messages non notre mandant honnêtement
bas c'est ma sixième marche et c'est la
première fois que je reçois vraiment
autant de soutien ça me fait plaisir et
ça motive vraiment tous les jours parce
que j'en reçois des centaines de
messages chaque jour ou les en sont
derrière moi à ta fille de jacques story
pour pour me motiver à faire une remise
de kilomètres
je crois que vous avez reçus parmi elles
les messages qui vous ont beaucoup
touchés émus à celle d'un joueur
algérien racontez nous un joueur
d'impact
ouais mourad meghni c'est un joueur que
mon père et il aimait beaucoup il le
suivaient beaucoup et ça m'a touché de
recevoir un message de soutien de sa
part donc voilà ça c'est des petites
choses qui
rajoute de la motivation toujours ce qui
rend votre aventure assez passionnante à
suivre mais dit dre pas c'est que vous
ne cachez rien non plus de vos moments
de blues intense peut-être je crois que
la journée d'hier est un bon exemple
vous pouvez peut-être de là nous l'a
raconté
hier ça s'est bien passé hier ça va ça
s'est bien passé que par contre j'ai
fait un défi je me suis lancé dans un
défi je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça
que j'ai décidé de me lancer un défi de
marché pendant 24 heures 17 heures du
matin à 7h du matin au lendemain et là
c'était vraiment là
l'état physique et psychologique trop
bas heureusement mais je suis resté en
live pendant ces 24 savent bien que les
gens pouvaient suivre et j'allais vous
lis pour eux demain si tu as son
physique est encore une fois j'ai reçu
un soutien magnifique parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont restés avec moi 24 heures
du début du live il a eu mais donc mais
chômage les jeunes manquent vraiment
tout ce qui se passe le quotidien et je
pense que c'est ça aussi qui peut plaire
aux gens de montrer les moments hauts et
les moments aussi difficiles qui font
partie de l'aventuré à quoi on pense
qu'en marche comme ça
ah on passe on passe un moment différent
il ya des moments on pense à sa vie il
ya des moments penser à ses amis à ses
proches il ya des moments on pense à
rien on regarde tout droit
beaucoup de choses
alors on a dit vous avez traversé la
france la suisse maintenant l'italie
fait très chaud là dans le sud de
l'europe et j'imagine que vous allez le
le confirmer ça risque de piquer niveau
température comment est-ce que vous
tenez physiquement
je m'hydrate bien et je suis attention
un vrai bal à aujourd'hui à 32 degrés de
prévu hier c'était 34 mais ça va toute
façon il faut faire avec peut pas faire
demi tour
j'en ai pas envie remplissent donc le
cas pas de souci la chaleur je crains
plus plus la chaleur la sicile en
tunisie en algérie peut-être avec des 45
degrés mais bon je vais aviser sauf que
à l'avs à l'arrivée en l'algérie en
algérie il ya une sacrée carottes 1
c'est votre grand père vous avez prévu
donc de lui faire une surprise quoique
vous avez prévu d'arriver fin septembre
a déjà comment peut-il ne pas savoir que
vous faites ce trajet avec la
l'exposition médiatique que vous avez et
ensuite qu'est ce que vous allez lui
dire quand vous serez devant sa porte
je vais commencer par la deuxième lui
dire
je me suis fait deux cents films
différents vraiment je me suis fait
plein de films je sais pas comment ça va
se passer je pense qu'on a dirig même
attendu par beaucoup de monde mais pas
par contre comment ça se fait qu'il pas
au courant je me pose la question
gg des renseignements en algérie et or
ont dit que du moment où il va être au
courant il rate tenir au courant les
autres membres de ma famille c'est sûr
donc si basse il est au courant c'est
ses parts avant la motivation
de rendre hommage à mon père
que le grand-père ces bonus
on imagine que y avoir un comité
d'accueil du coup s'il est au courant
assez costaud adjé qu'est ce que cette
aventure ou est ce qu'elle vous a emmené
déjà là où vous ne pensiez pas aller et
je parle pas en terme de cheminement
mais peut-être en termes de réflexion
plutôt
en termes de réflexion
déjà
g il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont
fait le parallèle entre entre la
situation que j'ai vécu et tout que des
millions de personnes ont vécu une
personne majeure par an
ça les a touchés et je savais pas que je
pouvais être aussi fédérateur et ça
c'est quelque chose qui me fait plaisir
donc je savais pas c'est pas que je
pouvais rassembler autant que personne
autour d'un projet un projet associatif
et en même temps
de partager mon expérience c'est que ça
puisse plaira autant de personnes donc
ça ça me fait ça me fait plaisir
et donc vous allez arriver à alger on le
disait c'est pas votre première marche
j'imagine que vous allez rentrer à paris
en avion mais après on reste pas
statique vous vous reprendrez vos
chaussures de marche et votre tante
oui oui je suis
j'ai un projet en tête
mais parti pour l'instant je pense je
pense à alger la capitale nous retrouver
là bas et pour la suite procédé
effectivement je verrai mes diplômes en
deux mots là l'objectif de la journée
c'est combien de kilomètres jusqu'à août
objectif de la journée pizza
bras dessous là
mais en tout cas l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est 34 km merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions d'avoir pris le
temps mais d'idées mois pour votre thé
du matin donc je rappelle le nom de dolo
angie ou un peu encore on peut encore
participer à votre cagnotte le lien sur
votre page instagram elle s'appelle life
ong et donc effectivement vous le disiez
le château d'eau auquel cette cagnotte
participer bien est en train d'être mis
en place dans un petit village au togo
merci encore bravo à vous et très bon
courage pour la suite de l'aventuré on
vous suivra jusqu'à alger mais dit merci
encore merci beaucoup très bonne journée
nous on se retrouve très vite sur
l'antenne de france 24